what's going on guys this is rob and
with comics explained focusing
exclusively on comic books
and pop culture explained focusing more
on tv
film different things like that this
video is actually going to go on
both channels now i know it's kind of
double dipping but at the same time it's
the only way i really know how to
consolidate the difference between the
two so
don't hate on me too much but in this
video what we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a disney plus series
for wolverine from the x-men i've
written out a lot of this and so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go through
this but as we do
there are a few things that i'll stop
and explain in order to make it make
sense and that's where the comic book
part comes in
so uh regarding the x-men in the marvel
cinematic universe because wolverine is
the most popular of the x-men both in
cinema and
comics it is my belief that while
introducing him in a movie
is and will be the most likely choice a
one season long
10 episode disney plus series can and
should expand
on information provided by the films
while none of the content
will be essential it will have the
benefit of adding to the existing mythos
of the x-men allowing the disney plus
brand and the marvel film brand to
effectively
feed one another now the reason why i
put here that it's not necessarily
essential is because kevin feige had
came out
and said that while the disney plus
series will have things like falcon in
the winter soldier
and loki and so on and so forth he does
not want disney plus to be treated as an
essential
read more or less for the marvel
cinematic universe in the sense that if
you go and you watch like a fantastic
four movie that you have to have seen
the disney plus reed richards episode in
order to understand what's going on and
that's a smart move
because that would potentially alienate
people because not everybody has the
time
or the money or both to sit down and
watch a 10 episode long series on disney
plus
and then go watch the movie right people
want to treat movies the way the marvel
cinematic universe movies have been
treated which is
self-contained unless they tie into
something else in the films i think that
will change as time goes on but at the
moment that's the general rule but
getting back into it
because of wolverine's age within marvel
comics and presumably the marvel
cinematic universe
this adds the benefit of being able to
bookend an explanation for the origin of
mutants within the marvel cinematic
universe effectively picking
up where the eternals film and
presumably the x-men film
leave off now assuming the eternals film
covers the modification of the human
genome by the celestials per the
mainline marvel comics see eternals vol
1 issue number one by jack kirby
the evolution of mutant kind beyond
these early changes
would likely be unexplained due to the
film focusing largely on the eternals
themselves
as opposed to the history of mutants
something else that i want to point out
here that i didn't actually write
the x-men film would largely focus on
the origin of mutants
if for no other reason than for us to
understand where they came from but even
with that movie focusing on the origin
of mutants there wouldn't be a lot of
time devoted to it because people are
going there to see the x-men
not to see the origin of the mutant
population and so combining this with
marvel's ultimate universe
origin of the mutant race not only
provides a breath of content that can be
used for the wolverine television show
but can also create a sense of cohesion
by tying into events that have already
transpired within the mcu
and so i propose the story of wolverine
combined with the origin of mutants
follows this form
on disney plus number one the eternals
film and the x-men film
established the creation of the mutant x
gene through genetic modification
this gene remains dormant from the time
the genes are modified
until the wolverine series now the
reason why i chose this is that in
marvel comics something i want to
specify
is how mutants came into existence so in
marvel comics mutants came into
existence through a couple different
ways
you have the main marvel universe way
and then you have the ultimate universe
way and they're distinctly different the
reason why the ultimate universe matters
is because the marvel cinematic universe
is based largely on the ultimate
universe so in the main marvel universe
line of comics what you had are these
celestial beings that were conducting a
universal wide experiment
and what they would do is they would
travel from one world to the next where
the inhabitants were very primitive
and they would take a small percentage
of that planus inhabitants and then
modify their genes
on the planet earth you had what were
called the wanderers and the wonderers
were largely presented to us in comics
as what was in effect the missing link
between primate man and modern man
essentially caveman as we would call it
and the idea was that this group the
wanderers had their numbers divided into
thirds
the first third were taken and had their
genes modified in such a way
to where they were in essence perfect
beings they could manipulate cosmic
energies they could fly
they had super strength and speed and
durability and all that kind of stuff
they were not
god-like they weren't able to like alter
reality on a universal scale
but they were exceedingly powerful this
group became known as
the eternals the second group had their
genes destabilized so that you would end
up having unchecked mutations and
because of the destabilization of their
genes
every generation that came after the
previous one would have a shorter and
shorter
lifespan now their lifespan was like
eons right like
hundreds if not potentially thousands of
years so you're talking about one
generation
they might live for 500 years the next
generation might live for 250 years the
third generation would live for half of
that
the fourth generation for half of that
that's how you would kind of see it
repeat itself now i'm just using
arbitrary numbers here
marvel is kind of fast and loose with
how long this race goes on for but this
group became known as the deviants
the fact that their genes were
destabilized is why they looked so
hideous in their appearance
and then the final group had their genes
modified in such a way so that two
things would happen
the first is that some of these genes
would basically become what we call
x genes meaning that during a time of
puberty or high duress those
x genes would activate that's where
mutants come from the second thing that
happened
is that for those individuals who did
not have an x gene that something may
happen over the course of their life
that would lend them to gaining powers
this is the way that marvel explains why
it is that somebody like bruce banner
could be exposed to gamma radiation
and not die of radiation poisoning and
instead become the incredible hulk
now switching over to the ultimate
universe the idea here is
totally different so in the ultimate
universe steve rogers was not the
original super
soldier instead it was nick fury and
what ended up happening is that the
super soldier serum was used on nick
fury but he escaped and went underground
and they couldn't find it but they did
verify
by virtue of nick fury that the super
soldier serum works
and so what they did is they brought in
steve rogers and steve rogers became
captain america now
while that was going on with nick fury
what ended up happening is that james
howlett was taken by canada by the
canadian government
and then inducted to what was in effect
the same super soldier experiment the
difference is that they discovered
a gene within his body that nobody knew
anything about and so they activated
this gene
and when they did wolverine developed a
healing factor following that they
bonded adamantium to his skeleton and he
went forward as wolverine right so
that's how
mutants came into existence but what
also came out of this was that the
activation of the mutant gene that
process was essentially synthesized and
it was spread throughout the world so
that mutant genes
all over the world suddenly began to
activate and that's where you get
mutants from in the ultimate universe so
again
two completely different ways of
bringing mutants into the marvel
cinematic universe potentially but they
both
effectively serve the same purpose and
so moving on this is when we get into
the meat and potatoes of the wolverine
series
okay so for the wolverine series
starting off at number one the series
would follow the life of wolverine
borrowing from both the mainline marvel
comics as well as the ultimate universe
line of comics including his involvement
in world war ii this can be done both by
using elements of daniel way's wolverine
origin comic series
as well as flashbacks of chris evans
captain america and while captain
america would be unaware of who
wolverine was at the very least it would
create a sense of cohesion with his
history
alongside the rest of the mcu and the
reason why i chose
daniel way's wolverine origin comic
series is because wolverine has had
quote unquote origin comics over the
years in marvel comics so if you look at
something like barry windsor smith's
marvel presents weapon x that gives you
the first depiction of wolverine's time
as part of the weapon x project becoming
wolverine the problem with this was that
it was a mainstay of wolverine's
character that he never really was able
to piece together his past
the significance of daniel way's comic
run is that in the aftermath of house of
m
one of the things that happened is that
all of wolverine's memories were
restored and that comic run
focuses on the restoration of those
memories and everything he learns about
himself that he previously didn't know
right so that's why that's so
important and of course seeing him
appear as flashbacks fighting alongside
captain america is cool
even if he doesn't really have like
adamantium claws or anything yet moving
on
number two due to the death of captain
america at the end of world war ii
hydra had secretly created the weapons
plus program
as a means to produce a new super
soldier to replace captain america and
had been conducting a series of
experiments and tests on various
individuals
as part of the weapons plus program each
of these tests would be designated as a
project with a specific numerical
value now i know a lot of you guys are
kind of curious about this i'm going to
go into this next section and then
explain
both of these right because the next
section is kind of important here and so
following this
number three wolverine would eventually
serve as part of team
x in the 1960s as far as the federal
government is aware
team x operates as a black ops team
carrying out various missions
on behalf of the american government in
his efforts to combat
communism secretly team x is used by
hydra having already infiltrated and
taken over shield
and the missions they carry out are
targets that stand as a direct threat
against
hydra's continued pursuit of power the
success of team x and their various
missions
leads hydra to believe that they would
stand as the best chance of recreating a
successful iteration
of the newer super soldier program now
let's explain these right because this
is probably the single most important
part of the series
and would really tie in to a lot of what
we see in the marvel cinematic universe
right so as we know at the end of
captain america the first avenger steve
rogers was believed to have been dead he
was actually frozen in ice but the
strategic science reserve as it was
created by peggy carter
and howard stark served the purpose of
basically allowing the government's
science wing to determine how they would
create different people or
bring different people in with different
abilities and so on and so forth
for example we saw during avengers
in-game in a flashback scene that the
strategic science reserve was familiar
with
brian bratt who would later go on to
become captain britain there's also
additional information to indicate that
the ssr
was familiar with joseph chapman and
john walker you guys may know these guys
as union jack or us
agent respectively the entire idea
behind the ssr as we know from captain
america the winter soldier
is that with arnhem zola being brought
in as essentially their science head
that he alongside a handful of others
had steadily begun to regrow hydra to
the point that hydra had actually
started to completely and totally take
over shield
but shield never actually knew that it
was happening now why does this matter
because in marvel comics what you have
is
weapons plus and weapons plus was an
overarching program designed to create
super soldiers now the motivation behind
weapons plus's origin
has different explanations for the sake
of this video it doesn't really matter
where weapons plus came from what does
matter is that weapons plus
their first project also known as weapon
one was codenamed
project rebirth that was the creation of
captain america we learned that
in grant morrison's new x-men run now
captain america was wildly successful
as we know he was the first and only
instance of being able to create a super
soldier serum that could be injected
into a human being
and that person would go on to become
someone who was the peak of human
physical conditioning the problem is as
we know
abraham erskine the creator of the super
soldier serum died and there was no way
to duplicate the process and so
following the perceived death of captain
america during world war
ii that weapons plus continued on with
its various projects weapons 2 weapon 3
weapon 4 5 6 7 8 9
basically using different iterations or
forms of technology to create different
types of super soldiers so you had
people like frank simpson for example
who had cybernetic implants grafted to
his body
and he also had this kind of mental
conditioning where he would have
different
uh pills that he would take for example
one pill would amp him up one pill would
keep him steady another pill would bring
him down different things along those
lines right grafting cybernetic
implants to animals trying to find ways
to control them and so on and so forth
for the second part of this in terms of
wolverine serving on team x in marvel
comics team x was a black
ops wet work team and the idea was that
they basically existed as a joint
venture between the united states cia
and canada's weapons plus and the idea
was that they would basically carry out
a series of missions
that were designed to either combat
communism or to take out various threats
to the united states they toppled
dictators and all kinds of stuff
now eventually team x was disbanded but
the idea was that when the team was
disbanded it was about three or four
years before weapons plus realized hey
like we know these guys have super
powers we know they have things like a
healing factor let's create a new
iteration of the weapons plus program
we'll call it weapon x and that's where
you got wolverine having adamantium
bonded to his skeleton by virtue of
professor thornton
and carol hines and professor cornelius
and so that's why these things matter
because what we're doing here is we're
basically saying that captain america
was
not part of weapons plus he predates it
but when hydra took
over shield that hydra created weapons
plus as a means to find a way to create
a new captain america type super soldier
that could be used for whatever
nefarious purposes hydra wanted to use
it
for and that the various projects that
came along all sort of happened
on the the back end sort of hidden away
from sight nobody really knew about it
and then once wolverine and sabertooth
and those guys become part of team x
working for hydra albeit unwittingly
that hydra realizes they've got powers
and they take them and put them into
weapons plus the newest project being
weapons 10 right weapon x so that's why
that's so important and that's why that
would probably be the single most
important part of this now following
this we say a metal urges anhydra
employee named myron mclean
is tasked with creating an
indestructible metal far stronger and
more durable than wakandan vibranium
by whatever manner and whatever means
myron maclaine creates adamantium but is
unable to duplicate the process now i
chose myron mclean here because he was
the creator of adamantium and marvel
comics that happened in avengers vol 1
issue number 66. now here's why this is
important and here's why this could have
a huge impact on the marvel cinematic
universe so the idea here was that in
marvel comics steve rogers had fought
alongside wakanda
against the germans when they were
trying to invade africa now at the time
captain america
shield was in an iron form and he was an
iron shape right the old school captain
america comics from like 1940s
you guys seen the cover it's literally
in the shape of an iron but when he was
fighting with the wakandans he realized
that while they did have shields having
a shield in the shape of a circle
was far more versatile that it could be
used in a defensive capacity
to block various attacks and things like
that but it could also be used
offensively throwing it at people
different things along those lines and
so what ended up happening here
is that because of his efforts in
fighting alongside the wakandans
specifically the grandfather of t'challa
i think it was
that steve rogers was rewarded with a
shard of vibranium and so what he did is
he returned back to the united states
and he told the us government to
basically create a new shield that was
round
and then to put the vibranium inside of
it and so what ended up happening is the
us government contracted a man named
iron maclaine and meyer mclean
much like the invention of penicillin
for example had ended up creating
captain america shield as it exists now
by accident it ended up happening is he
quite literally fell asleep behind the
wheel and that when he woke up the
captain america shield had solidified
but it was not composed exclusively
of wakandan vibranium that instead it
actually turned out to be what kind of
vibranium and some other element that we
weren't necessarily familiar with now
what we end up learning later on
is that captain america's shield is
composed of wakandan vibranium
steel and a third element that no one's
ever been able to discover
presumably it was adamantium but nobody
really knows for certain the important
thing behind this
is that myron mclean tried to duplicate
captain america shield and when he did
he was not able to copy it but he
created adamantium instead
and that's where adamantium comes from
that's why meyer mclean is chosen here
he's the guy who created it but
moving on number five team x is taken by
hydra and inducted into the weapons plus
program as his tenth test or project
effectively rebranding wolverine as
weapon x
now during the initial screening process
hydra discovers the mutant gene within
wolverine
activates it and finds that he has a
healing factor adamantium as it was
created by myron mclean
is bonded to his skeleton now initially
i put on here that this could be used to
explain where scarlet witch and
quicksilver got their powers from for
scarlet witch that doesn't apply anymore
we know that at the end of one division
that her powers are basically the
inherent ability to manipulate the
various magical energies of the entirety
of the universe that's what makes her
more powerful than steven strange but
with quicksilver we don't know where he
got his powers from
and so what we can say here is that
quicksilver is actually a mutant
he is a legitimate mutant but unlike the
scarlet witch his powers were activated
by virtue of baron von strucker's use of
the mind stone
from loki's scepter and that's where we
can say the mutants have been popping up
at different points in the marvel
cinematic universe we just didn't know
what they were and so finishing this off
the rest of the wolverine series would
follow wolverine's exploits after
escaping the weapons plus facility
eventually leading up to his meeting
with charles xavier and joining the
x-men which would allow the series
to bookend directly into the x-men film
however that film starts off
that's how we end the wolverine series
but that's my idea for this right that's
my whole idea for this let me know what
you guys think if there's anything that
was a little confusing here let me know
down in the comment section i'll do my
best to expand on it and explain it a
little bit better
but i think it was pretty
straightforward here i think we hit all
the important points
one of the cool things about this too is
i've actually got this for a bunch of
different characters i've got ideas like
this for magneto
for like professor xavier for colossus
for nightcrawler different things like
that
it's just these ideas designed to kind
of introduce these characters into the
marvel cinematic universe by giving them
a disney plus series that helps to beef
up whatever information we get in the
various films that they have
if it's like a solo film or like just
the overall x-men film
or something along those lines so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later peace